hi
my name is mark everett from the mayo
clinic uh and i'm excited
to join you all today and to share some
of our recent research
and what we're focusing on is
how long-range technologies uh help
resolve
complex genomic regions that are often
overlooked by shortly
read sequencing so you know as as we all
know short-range sequencing
has many uh applications and a lot of
value but there are
certain aspects uh in our research that
that are really really lending
themselves better to
uh long read sequencing and i want to
highlight some of that today
so basically short reads they overlook
two critical types of genomic variants
that that we believe are are really
important
in human health and disease and those
two basic categories
are first variants that fall in what are
called
dark or what we in in certain situations
term
camouflaged regions and
i'll go more in depth about what that is
here in a moment
the second category of genomic variants
that is often overlooked by
by short reads are structural variants
and those are generally categorized as
variants that
include at least 50 contiguous
nucleotides
so what i'm showing here in the image to
the
to the left is uh is a large structural
deletion in the cr1 gene uh that we
are able to monitor and measure with the
bio nano genomics optical mapping dna
mapping technology
and on the right we're showing a large
uh
2100 base pair deletion that we observed
in a gene with
with long read technologies
so let's talk for a minute about
what exactly dark and camouflaged
regions are
and you know do we care you know that
long read technologies can resolve them
why why should we care
so what exactly is a are these dark
regions so
we we categorize them into two basic
groups of
dark by depth or dark by mapping quality
so with dark by depth that's basically a
region of the genome that when we
sequence
you know an individual's dna we don't
get
reads at that region there just are no
reads
and an example that we're showing here
is hla drb5
where in many individuals this region
is is at least or approximately 50
percent dark
in coding regions and you can see this
in the
blank areas the where there are no reads
and just to kind of
orient you what we're looking at is a
pile up of of short aluminum reads for
an individual
where each little gray bar represents
an individual reed and and and
typically what you would expect is to
see a nice
deep pile up of these reeds as you see
at the beginning of the gene
but as you get deeper into the gene you
see these large gaps where there just
are no reeds so that's dark bite that
the the second category is what we call
dark by mapping quality and this is a
very different
scenario but has the same end result
where
basically you cannot get you cannot
observe or measure variants or mutations
in these regions
so with dark by mapping quality what's
happening as you can see with
within hspa1a at the beginning of the
gene
we see a lot of nice gray bars deeply
stacked and those
the gray bars indicate that it's aligned
uh
well by the aligner and as you get
deeper into the gene you see these
sort of transparent bars which are reads
that are aligned but have a mapping
quality
of zero and so
the aligner didn't know how to handle
these reads and we'll talk about why in
a moment
but later when the structural excuse me
when the variant caller is coming along
looking for mutations it sees this
entire pile of reeds that have
a poor mapping quality and just ignores
them so in both of these situations
whether it's dark by depth or dark by
mapping quality
the the variant collar as it comes along
just it completely
ignores these regions and does not you
know indicate to you
or or your vcf file does not indicate
that or your list of variants does not
indicate that that these regions are
are completely overlooked
so uh talking specifically more about
the dark by mapping quality these are
the regions that we call
camouflage and the reason
that we consider them camouflage is
they're they're dark by mapping quality
because of a genomic duplication
so what's happening here we're showing
an example of hsp a1a
and hsp a1b there are two genes just
down the road from each other in the
genome
and they're nearly identical
through about half of the genes and
you can visually see the the transparent
bars very
very you know immediately which region
is is camouflaged and
what's happening is these genes are
camouflaging each other
so when we we use short reads
and you get a read that can align
equally well to two or more places
the aligner doesn't know where to put it
and so it randomly assigns it to one of
those locations and gives it a mapping
quality at zero
and then you know has the downstream
consequences that we previously
discussed
so that's what camouflage genes are
so they you know the big question was we
in our research we started to bump into
some genes
that we felt were or we knew were
important
with our research and uh alzheimer's
disease
als frontal temporal dementia and
uh we were kind of surprised that that
they were dark
uh or camouflaged and so that really got
us thinking
how big is this problem uh so i should
i should state that that you know in
genomics
in the field of genomics and
bioinformatics we've known for years
that
that there were regions like this we
knew that the problem existed but
no one really knew how big the problem
was
and so you know as we started to see
some important genes that are being
affected we decided we needed to
to dig into this and see how big the
problem is
so when we did that uh we found
that over 6 000 gene bodies are at least
partially dark uh according based on
hg38
reference genome 527 of those
are completely dark from end to end and
that really surprised us
so we then started to dig in to get you
know more details you know what kind of
gene bodies are these and what areas of
a gene
before i get to that um uh here i'm
showing
a a plot of percent
darkness for each gene so
uh on the on the y-axis is percent
darkness and on the
x-axis is each gene in rank order based
on the darkness
and as i mentioned 527 genes are
completely dark
if we set a threshold of at least 25
percent dark there are over 1600
and over 2100 or at least five percent
dark
but you know as i mentioned the big
question then for us was okay what kind
of gene bodies are these gene bodies is
a fairly big
term so uh
when we looked at uh gen code
uh classifications we determined we were
able to determine that almost
four thousand of these six thousand gene
bodies are actually protein coding
uh followed by link rnas
and various other rnas so
this surprised us we did not expect most
of them to be protein coding
um so then we just then we wanted to
know okay what
which area of a protein-coding gene or
other genes
gene bodies is most affected
and unsurprisingly the the bulk of them
were intronic as you see in the bar plot
to the right and
followed by introns were exons from
non-coding rnas
and then actual coding regions cbs
regions
and then followed by five prime and
three prime utrs
so while we're not surprised that the
majority of these regions are intronic
uh you know there are a lot of i think a
lot of researchers tend to
discredit the importance of introns in
biology but there are actually a lot of
disease-causing mutations that are in
chronic
uh such as the c9r 72 g4 c2 repeat
expansion which i'll talk a little bit
more about later in my presentation
so um from from here on in my
uh uh in my talk i'm gonna describe
and focus mostly on the coding regions
genes that are affected
where at least five percent of the
coding exons
are dark or camouflaged so
zeroing in on those uh we found that 117
genes
are 100 dark encoding regions
and almost 600 genes are at least five
percent dark
in coding regions so again narrowing
down and
and zooming in on these uh genes that
are at least
five percent dark you know we wanted to
know
what what pathways what gene families
might be involved in this
and uh and we were surprised and found
that there are some
some really important uh pathways that
are affected that are
where at least five percent of the gene
the coding region is overlooked and
these pathways are relevant to human
health
and development and even reproductive
function
um as you can see
we also wanted to look and see
you know are any of these particular
genes known to
interact directly physically and some of
these genes
do including hspa1a and some other
important genes
so then the big question for us was
okay we've we've determined that there
are a lot of protein coding
and other in other gene bodies that are
completely overlooked but partially
overlooked
when we're doing short read sequencing
so how many of these genes are already
known to be involved in human disease
and we found that 76 genes that are at
least five percent dark in cvs regions
have known mutations that are associated
with
human disease uh in this case 326
unique human diseases and what i'm
showing is a word cloud
of these 76 genes where the size of the
gene
in this figure indicates the number of
diseases that
that it's known to be involved in so for
example nab
is involved in over 24 human diseases
including memoline myopathy
and there's some some of these genes
that i'm going to focus on but you
know you might be wondering now is my
favorite gene
uh partially dark or camouflaged
and this is really what caught our eye
as you can
hopefully you can see there in the
middle right next to nab
is cr1 cr1 is a top alzheimer's disease
gene
and i've been in alzheimer's disease
genetics for about eight years
you know working specifically with
genomics data
and i had never heard anyone talk about
cr1 being dark or camouflaged and i had
never noticed it either
so this was a real eye-opener for us and
really what
spurred a lot of this work and i'll talk
a little bit more about cr1 here in a
minute i want to briefly focus on
smn1 and smn2 which are
genes that are known to cause spinal
muscular atrophy
and they've also been implicated in
amylotrophic lateral
sclerosis or als so
smn1 and smn2 are over 90
camouflaged by again by each other
and what i'm showing in this figure is
a histogram of coverage
from a large data set known as the from
the nomad consortium
so this this data set has uh
nearly 150 000 whole genomes
and whole egg zones primarily exomes
and this is showing a histogram from
their data of the coverage for this
gene smn1 and the reason i'm showing
this is i want to just emphasize this
isn't just a problem in some of
our data it wasn't a technical artifact
from
from our sequencing this is ubiquitous
across all short read data sets
so smn1 and smn2 are nearly completely
camouflaged
similarly cr1 again as i mentioned a
really important gene in alzheimer's
disease is the top five gene
uh over approximately i guess exactly 20
of it is is dark or in this case it's
actually
camouflaged and what's unique about cr1
is it's camouflaged by itself
uh because within the gene there's a
tandem repeat of the c3b c4b binding
domain
and according to hg38 it's repeated
approximately three times and uh
that creates the alignment issue that we
previously discussed
so this was you know again a real eye
opener for us
so okay hopefully uh you know to this
point i've i've
convinced you that there are there are
some you know
holes some dark and camouflaged regions
that need to be addressed so what can we
do about it
um well there are kind of two approaches
one
is is one that we came up with for
existing short read data sets and i'm
just going to briefly describe that so
that you're aware that it exists
but i want to emphasize that we consider
it simply a band-aid
and that we think long term uh long read
and long range uh sequencing approaches
are
the solution to this problem and others
the and the structural variants as we'll
discuss
so briefly just describing our our
algorithm that we designed we wanted to
know
with these really large datasets that
already exist from short read sequencing
and more will continue to be
created you know is there a way to
rescue mutations from some of these
regions
and we came up with a conceptually
simple approach
where basically if we have a region that
is repeated in the genome
uh as in in this example i'm showing
exons 10 18 and 26 within cr1 are
repeated
all the the reads get randomly from
those exons they get randomly assigned
to those three
exons with a mapping quality of zero
demonstrated by the transparent reads in
in figure b
well if we sort of trick the aligner
and make it as though two of those three
exons do not exist
we can then align all the reads to just
one of those exons
and we can then determine that you know
we then get
good mapping quality and we can call
variance
so what we can then do is determine that
a variant exists
in one of these three exons but we
cannot tell you at this point is which
exon it is that exists but then you can
follow up with other approaches to
to really zero in on that uh so that's
the
basic you know summary of that that
algorithm we applied it to the
alzheimer's disease sequencing project
which is at the time we had access to
thirteen thousand whole genomes and
exomes
and we were able to rescue over four
thousand variants from those
uh samples and again because cr1 was a
top
alzheimer's disease gene that was
camouflaged we specifically interrogated
that gene to see if there were any
you know i guess you know
quote unquote smoking guns you know for
alzheimer's disease
and we did identify a 10 base pair frame
shift deletion
that is in uh one of those three
exons and it's it's very rare
uh but we found it in five alzheimer's
these cases and zero controls and since
then we've also found in additional
cases
and we're continuing to follow this up
so just again just sort of a proof of
principle
that in these dark and camouflaged
regions there are important variants
that we need to be
that we can't miss we can't afford to
miss them
so that's the brief description of our
our algorithm but again
you know we view the long read
technologies as
as the real solution long term
so we wanted to know you know just how
well do
long read technologies address this
problem
so we did a comparison uh
using standard illumina sequencing with
a 100 base pair read links
as the baseline and then we started to
compare
longer read technologies and how much
of these dark regions are resolved
with them so the the three technologies
that we
are that we that we compared are 10x
genomics
long excuse me synthetic long read
technology pac bio and oxford nanopore
technologies
and what we found and we're showing here
in figure b
is that 10x genomics it
resolves approximately 50 percent of
dark and camouflaged regions uh
relative to alumina
standard illumina sequencing pac bio
resolves about 64
these numbers are inverted showing how
much of how much of it
remains so back bio resolves about 64
and oxford nanopore technologies
resolves
about 91 percent of these dark and
camouflaged regions
uh really just demonstrating that these
laundry technologies
have a lot of value in in resolving
these regions
i should also just briefly highlight
that 10x genomics their
synthetic boundary technology was
unfortunately recently just
discontinued which is uh you know as i
said very unfortunate but
um here i wanted to demonstrate some
uh some specific examples showing
how these different technologies fare in
some of these regions we discussed so
with smn1 and sma2
in the top we're showing the large gaps
that you would see
based on standard illumina sequencing
in these regions 10x genomics resolves
them very well
with their synthetic long reads and
impact bio also resolves the region
but if you look at the histogram above
the the reads
you'll see that pac bios read death does
drop dramatically
throughout the gene in the middle of
those genes
and then finally oxford nanopore
technologies uh resolves them
uh you know perfectly well uh where
there is no drop in coverage
in either of those those genes
and then cr1 which is you know has has
become
a favorite gene of mine here showing
again
the top alumina you see these large gaps
10x genomics has zero effect on these
regions
again pac bio does resolve the regions
but the coverage does drop pretty
dramatically in the middle uh and then
oxford nanocore technologies also
resolves this region with with uh with
pretty strong coverage throughout that
region
again so this is just demonstrating some
specific
specific examples where the long read
technologies
uh resolve these regions
so uh you know to this point i've talked
about the first category of how long we
and long-range technologies help resolve
dark and camouflaged regions but how
about the structural variants that we've
discussed
that we or that we mentioned so
i just want to briefly show some some
unpublished data
that we have where we first
tested some targeted deep targeted
sequencing with pac-bile on 20 subjects
for 15 genes that are of interest to us
and i wanted to highlight here so
there are a lot of numbers on this slide
where we're showing 12
of the 20 samples that we that we
sequenced in these
15 genes and we're just we just broke it
up into
the number of insertions and deletions
structural
insertions and deletions that we
observed in these genes in these
individuals
and then we also broke it up into how
many of them were
i uh in other words had never been
observed before
and the take-home number here the
message is in red
in the lower right hand corner where we
identified an average
of 10.3 de novo
structural mutations across these 15
genes per individual
and that's a lot of structural mutations
that have never been observed before
from just 20 subjects that we selected
again just highlighting that there are a
lot there's a lot of structural
radiation out there that is not being
captured with shore read technologies
uh and here i'm just showing a specific
uh
long uh large deletion in the cv2ap gene
which is
a a top alzheimer's disease gene
so i also wanted to briefly um or i
guess
you know show another technology
that is that is optical dna mapping from
bio nano genomics
that has a different uh application it's
really
uh it's it's great strength is in the
the extremely long dna fragments
and the ability to identify structural
variants
um so what i'm showing here is just a
view of
their chip uh so basically uh
on on the on the lower figure it shows
a at the microscopic level how
the technology works so basically they
have they get
you extract high molecular weight dna
and that dna gets
or i should say really long dna
fragments
now dna gets teased carefully into these
long
dna excuse me nano channels that are
about the width of a dna
brand so i'm going to
show a brief video showing
how this technology works where you'll
actually be able to see the dna being
carefully teased into these nano
channels
so i really like that video it's just
just a beautiful image showing how you
know showing this technology but let me
highlight uh some of the data that we've
generated with this technology and the
value of it
so we you know in our efforts to test
the technology ourselves
we selected some samples that we had
access to some brain samples
um that we wanted to test you know how
well can this technology
identify some known structural mutations
or variants and one of those is an a
known alpha synuclein triplication that
was implicated in parkinson's disease
years ago by singleton and fair at all
and this is a a triplication
that our knowledge was was described but
had
but the the haplotype structures had not
been
uh characterized or at least published
that we had seen
so we we had access to
[Music]
brain tissue from one of these uh
subjects
and we ran that and uh on the
on the on the sapphire the bionaut
sapphire and and
as i had a quick a quick first pass we
just did a copy number variation
analysis and you can see that
here where uh as we walk along you see
two copies of
of the genome and then it quickly spikes
and
we see four copies and then it drops
back down to two copies and it's about a
two megabase region so it's
it's a pretty large region we
immediately are able to identify that
so then we started to you know we dug in
and what is really exciting about this
technology
is one that we can identify
really large and complicated structural
variants
but two that we can actually construct
individual haplotypes
so in this case we're able to construct
both
germline haplotypes from this individual
so what i'm showing uh
the green horizontal bar that indicates
uh chromosome four from the reference
human genome
where alpha synuclein is which is
indicated there in the middle
the top uh horizontal blue line
is the the first haplotype that was
constructed
using the optical dna mapping
technology and each blue
hash on on both bars
indicates a motif that has been tagged
and that's how we
are able to construct the structure of
of the haplotypes
each gray line between those indicates
an alignment
so comparing haplotype 1 to chromosome 4
all the the gray lines are completely
vertical indicating that there is no
no structural rearrangement in this
region if we look at haplotype 2 however
we're showing just a portion where we
see two inversions
and so we're able to see based on this
that
first of all the first the the one
haplotype
is completely normal so the triplication
all happened on a single apple type
and and we're also able to determine
that while with all three being on the
same
haplotype two of those copies are
actually inverted
so this just really demonstrates uh
is one great example of the power of
this technology
another example that we tested was
using the c9r72 g4c2 repeat expansion
that is known to cause
als and frontotemporal dementia
so we have uh we had a case
that has a really large expansion that's
shown in the southern blot
indicated by the blue arrow and we knew
that the expansion was quite large
it was larger than 23 kilobases
but you with with
you know some of these older
technologies it's hard to be uh really
precise so we wanted to see
whether the sapphire is able to span and
measure
these extremely large repeat expansion
expansions where
no other technology has really been able
to do this at the depth and consistency
that the bio nano can at the sapphire
can
so again what i'm showing here the green
bar
indicates chromosome 9 where c9 or 72
resides and then we actually were able
to construct
five different haplotypes showing
various
lengths of this expansion which we
had suspected and we also showed on a
previous publication
that there is mosaicism of this
expansion
in this case the expansion is exists
in various sizes of repeats and so we
observed
everything from 1.9 kb expansion
up to a haplotype of 31.6 kb
when we looked at the individual dna
molecules we actually
observed one molecule where the
expansion was
45 kb just demonstrating how
large of a of a an expansion we're able
to measure
this technology
um and and i should you know point out
you cannot do that you cannot size that
with
short read technology that's simply not
possible
um so using cr1 as a you know another
example i
i alluded to the the region the
the binding domain that is a tandem
repeat what i hadn't explained before
is that this binding domain
the the number of times it's repeated is
actually variable in the population and
the number of times it's repeated
is associated with disease so
you know today you know there's there
has not been a good way
to accurately measure the number of
binding domains within an individual and
certainly not
broken up by haplotype but with this
technology we're able to do that
and then lastly i wanted to show the
the histocompatibility complex which
houses the human antigen leukocyte genes
or the hla genes
this region is is genomically complex
there's a lot of variation
in the population here this region has
also been
implicated with over a hundred human
diseases
but because of the genomic uh complexity
it's been hard to really pin down what's
happening
well with the with the sapphire optical
dna mapping
we're able to construct complete
haplotypes
throughout this entire region and
part of what we're showing here are the
red regions which indicate
genomic variation from the human
reference so
sequence that has not been observed in
the human reference
so with that you know i just want to
summarize and you know thank you for
you know joining me today um i what i
hope i was able to
to to demonstrate is that there are some
really important
regions of the human genome be it from
dark or camouflaged regions
that are completely overlooked or
structural the variants that are in
regions that we are able to sequence uh
well but that are overlooked
again with short-re technologies and
and and hopefully demonstrate the value
of these long read
and long-range technologies and what we
can do with them there are a lot of
genes
that are already known to be involved in
disease that are
not being adequately interrogated
with the right technologies or maybe i
should say with all of the right
technologies
and that's what we're working on and
what we hope
you know we've convinced uh you all of
their utility
so again thank you for joining me and
i'll be happy to take any questions
thank you